هل فقدت الولايات المتحده صبرها مع ايران
مؤخرا الاجابه هنا تتحدث عنها صحيفه
الامريكيه نيويورك تايمز التي تقول ان
طيران لم تترك لواشنطن خيارا سوا بدء حقبه
جديده من المواجهه المباشره
الصحيفه الامريكيه تقول ان الدبلوماسيه
واشنطن انتهت والسبب يعود الى سياسات
الثيران فيما يتعلق بالسياسه الخارجيه
اوجد التحالف الايراني
اما داخليا شكل قمع السلطات الايرانيه
العنيف المحتاجين عائقا كبيرا امام اي
تطبيق ممكن العلاقات او محاوله احياء
الاتفاق النوويه
[موسيقى]
عمل اخر دفعه واشنطن لنهج اكثر تشددا مع
ايران سببه تاظم تهديد تهران الامن الدولي
اكثر من اي وقت مضى اسباب كثيره اخرى
تحدثت عنها الصحيفه اولها تاثر الوصول
لنتيجه على طاوله مفاوضات الاتفاق النووي
وعرفت ايران قبول زياره مفتش الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه لمواقعها النوويه
اضافه الى تسريع ايران تخصيب الايرانيوم
بنسبه 60 بالمئه داخل منشات التي تثير
شبهات بانشطه العسكريه
لكن يبدو وفق نيورك ساينز ان الولايات
المتحده بدات تضع خطه مواجهه عسكريه
والتضرر على ضرب منشاه فورد النوويه
والمحصنه وسط الجبال